Right.
Well mathematicians always talk about beauty
in mathematics but we’ve never been quite
clear whether it’s the same kind of beauty,
same appreciation of beauty, as people have
in the arts and humanities.
So, together with my colleagues at University
College London who work in neuroscience, we
devised an experiment.
And this experiment — which nowadays you
can conduct without cutting people open, you
have marvelous technology — well to cut
a long story short, this experiment showed
conclusively that the part of the brain that
appreciates mathematical beauty is the same
part of the brain that appreciates beauty
in other fields.
So scientifically it’s been — and that’s
subject to all sorts of scientific tests done
with the right technologies and statistics
and so published to the right journals — and
it showed convincingly that in fact what we
mathematicians describe as beauty or appreciation
of beauty is fundamentally the same as the
notion of beauty shared by our colleagues
in the arts and humanities.